with the new trailer for once upon a
Deadpool seeing release I thought I'd
break down everything that you need to
know about the upcoming film's release
I've compiled all of the information
that I could find on the film to let you
know before you go in what to expect
there may be slight spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything yet then
I suggest that you turn off now but
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to okay so the first thing that you
should know about once upon a Deadpool
is that it's actually a recur of
Deadpool - in order to fit a pg-13
rating Ryan Reynolds stated that this
was because Fox have been asking for a
pg-13 version of the character for a
long time and that the studio were
willing to pay a large amount of the
proceedings to charity that charity
being fudge cancer the film itself
features eight new scenes with some that
massively pay homage to the Princess
Bride
this is why Fred Savage stars as the
main person playing off the Merc with a
mouth Savage was the original star of
The Princess Bride so it makes sense to
cast him here
the film is set as a bedtime story with
Deadpool recounting the detail to savage
as we listen to events play out the
movie is rumored to be Disney's Way of
testing the war up for how they will
move forward and incorporating the
character into their MCU franchise the
movie is also set to release in China
which I believe that Deadpool 2 did not
it makes a lot of sense to do this as
China was missed and obviously the
country holds a lot of weight in the
foreign market so no we won't be getting
a totally new film and those who already
own the super duper car of Deadpool 2
may see this as a waste of money but hey
it's for charity so I guess it's not all
bad so what are your thoughts on once
upon a Deadpool are you excited to see
the film and will you be revisiting
theaters upon its release comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then make sure you like it and
check out my review of Deadpool - super
duper Kirk which will be linked at the
end of this video this is the channel
for people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care
peace
[Music]